grown-up games meant everything to me
even even when I was you know in my
grandmother's basement playing Nintendo
64 with six different cousins and we
have the pass the joystick around but
you know as I got older it was a
sometimes an escape today games mean you
know everything to myself or my team all
of us are extremely passionate about
games we spend all of our free time and
even some of our work time playing games
talking about games and to be able to
build a company and where kids can you
know validate their passion and be
recognized for you know their talents
and in a way that they've never done
before I had the opportunity to do
before it's pretty exciting for us
[Music]
so what we do I play versus is building
an infrastructure for high school
eSports and a part of that we've also
built the official platform in which the
competitions themselves run on and so
yes in other words we're introducing
video games as an actual sanctioned
sport in 20,000 high schools across the
country
[Music]
I think you know an entrepreneurship
especially as a founder and the CEO
especially the journey is lonely is you
know long the days are hard but you know
you have to be extremely persistent and
you have to sort of roll with the
punches and keep going I define success
in two ways for us one I define success
in impact so you know how many kids to
send to college how many kids do we make
Pro how many kids do we make just
successful people the second way for us
is through impact in the industry we
want to be the most important company
gamer and certainly the most valuable
[Music]
being on a thirty under thirty lists
it's pretty amazing
it's humbling you know considering where
I come from I grew up in the Jeffers
projects in Detroit so to be on the 30
under 30 list is especially not only for
me I think for you know all of the kids
who look like me who you know didn't
have the privilege to drink hopefully
seeing me on the list inspire so another
thinking
[Music]
you